I'm Janna Levin.
I'm the director of sciences at here at Pioneer
Works in Red Hook, Brooklyn.
Pioneer Works is a center for art and events
and science.
It's really just an open, spirited place where
everybody brings to it what they have to offer.
When I first came to Pioneer Works I was scientist
in residence and I was finishing a book on
black holes and people couldn't really understand
why I would come to write a science book at
this art space where it was loud and noisy
and dusty and people were working and exhibits
were coming and going.
But for me it was this perfect distraction
and I would be so inspired watching the exhibits
come and go and it would really help me kind
of find a tone and a pace and a way to focus
on my own seemingly unrelated work.
So most of the time I really am doing hard
core scientific research.
I mean my work is very theoretical.
I'm very interested in black holes.
I'm interested in gravitational waves, the
shape of space-time, whether extra dimensions
can trap dark energies.
It's very abstract, theoretical, mathematical
physics.
But then when I'm writing I feel like it's
something totally different.
When I'm writing, I'm thinking about the pace
and energy of a story.
It's different but the content is still usually
very scientific.
I love these conceptual ideas and the sense
in which abstract concepts can really shape
and structure a story.